are you Toronto I'm from Toronto cool s
yeah cool yeah you've been huh
I've never been to Toronto I married a
Vancouver E and thank you right so
that's important yeah and I've been to
Montreal a bunch which is beautiful I
love that yeah
Vancouver's over here yeah and then
Toronto's over here if you're buying the
map yes well for her of it you were
gonna camera very cool you can do like a
royal illustration and your viewers will
go yeah right what trial I think you
guys are Canadian now okay please let's
talk about single parents could we could
gravy on french fries but what else can
you get cheese she's cursed oh yes it
melted why are we doing this now I know
I'm sad yeah
single parents could be great truck I
would like to know I want what you know
come on that day come there has to be a
poutine truck called poutine on the Ritz
right he's so good if not do we all go
in poutine on the Ritz
so we got to talk about single parents
single parents is shooting season two
yeah what can you tell us everybody does
season one was sort of introductions
like any television show is and and you
met my character will and he was
introduced to Layton's character Angie
and the rest of the group and it was if
if season one had a through-line it was
about Rick getting wheel back on track
to be a functional human being and so
far from what we've sort of seen in red
this one's gonna focus a little more on
Angie and about her sort of abandonment
issues and and what she's had in
partners past what she is having in
partners present and what she's looking
for in partners future it's very
I was gonna say it's just like screwed I
saw that - we know what we've done to
you so we'll hang for two more so you
both have had well first of all your
husband Adam Brody he was in the finale
yes what was that like working with him
great love it I love all collaborations
with him I love him being on set I love
him being at home no you know very good
at home yeah he's great you ever seen
him at home
have you ever oh god he starts it he
make some eggs a magician he puts the
kid to bed lights out I love him on set
I want him to come back hopefully he
will and we'll see what happens with
that character he's the father of my
child you know in the show as well and
but he hasn't been there for Angie and
it's made her real skittish and I think
she's like coming to terms with him
possibly coming back possibly being in
her life she's open this can of worms
and she doesn't know where she's headed
now and it's kind of like turned her
universe upside down so um we'll see
that unfold in a very funny way
hopefully and then your wife Canadian
yeah big deal to us yeah
will she be guest starring on the show
at all in season two I know was she's
starring on an ABC show yeah it just
make sense
it's tricky it's Jackie I don't know
what the what the sort of like you know
corporate position is on on you know
we're literally on at 9:30 and she's on
at 10:00 so if you go from watching a
show or she's playing a different
character into her show or she's playing
Dex I like is that confusing or is it
great I don't know I would love a
crossover I'd love her to be around cool
that was the first time I ever flew by
myself when I was like maybe 10 was that
was the name of the flight attendant Oh
the pilot is your flight yeah it's
pretty amazing
oh it deposits the pilot is the flight
that you took that's
right on the Ritz ask one more question
because we've been so busy okay we love
you we love you everybody's doing their
job and I am grateful to you all
um the Gossip Girl reboot right are you
thinking about it is a great show she
was wonderful I started watching it last
season in my trailer yeah I mean she's
so wonderful she's also cute little
little baby girl
yeah baby girl it's over ten years now
or close to it has to be really eighteen
years thirteen we don't know yet
is the official answer we don't know
very close friends
this last surf buddy and he's my manager
so you guys don't know we don't know
we're still not clear what streaming
service it's on if I'm being honest okay
yeah I do know I'm on a show called
single parent up yeah that's Michelle
yeah we've done so many bit actually
one bit is that I play four characters
on it and it's gonna be like a Nutty
Professor thing for me where I play like
the two leads I actually quit after this
I'm done guys you can't I love you it's
been fun
I'm gonna go back to the beach
they're so I appreciate you're so lovely
thank you thank you very much